l'autre martin geloux cardiologue et
directeur de la prévention de l'institut
de cardiologie de montréal et bonsoir
docteur juneau
ça doit faire baver 25 ans vous que vous
parlez contre la viande rouge en
essayant de démontrer les effets
néfastes quand vous recevez ce comme ça
35 ans maintenant quand vous recevez
comme ça la une du new york times à la
une du monde
ces conclusions là on est habituellement
du dew 6 publics qui sont ces gens là je
suis dit statisticien mais c'est pas des
méthodologies s'est pas déjà en
nutrition des experts dans le domaine et
c'est probablement des disciples d'un
professeur de stanford qui s'appelle
ioannidis qui ne considère sacré que les
études randomisées contrôlées wsws année
cette grande maîtrise et que vous
vous choisi au hasard dans quel groupe
va être la personne qui prend place et
vous il prend la pilule active c'est bon
en pharmacologie mais dans le domaine
par exemple de l'environnement la
pollution de l'exercice de du cabba
zizou si jamais des études randomisées
c'est toujours les données
épidémiologiques des études de cohorte
qui donne des hypothèses
après ça on fait des études en
laboratoire des animaux sur des humains
à court terme
comprendre ce pion du bes a du sens les
mécanismes qui ont du sens puisque
corroborent les données de cours qui
prétendent avoir étudié à 61 1 article
sur 5 ans mais dans une petite maison
ils ont exclu universal ils ont exclu
des études randomisées de grande valeur
on sait pas pourquoi les sud de lyon par
exemple est tout près du med alors ce
tout le monde déjà pointé ça ils ont
inclus des études très bonne et pourquoi
ce journal avait là l'association
américaine american association of et
gestion des médecins c'est un hommage au
lendemain de ce noël pourquoi et puis
bah moi je pensais la 3e manche est le
il ya tellement une crise dans la public
dans les publications médicales tous les
journaux médicaux veulent faire les
manchettes ça augmente l'impact facture
comme on dit alors les chercheurs m
publiés dans des revues à gros impact la
publicité est plus payante à ce moment
là c'est malheureux mais plusieurs
chercheurs qui l'on dit aujourd'hui qui
demande un retrait corps et des
carrément des six passive est ce que
c'est ce papier dans les dix
indépendants
oui ça c'est vrai je n'ai pas vu de lien
moi j'ai regardé comme il faut et il ya
aucun lien avec une industrie quelqu'un
parce qu'on prend
non lobé et marion des siens qui quitte
une chercheur connue dans le domaine de
la nutrition depuis longtemps qui étudie
beaucoup les lobbys elle le cherche
c'est étonnant qu'avoir écrit autant de
sorties il n'y a pas quelqu'un derrière
parce que des courses vraiment de
deux choses mal fait il recommande de
s'en tenir à quatre portions de viande
rouge par semaine
mais oui et puis ce qui est curieux
c'est que leurs propres données montrent
que bénéfices à manger moins de viande
puis à moi mais on le sait sur une
population générale c'est le risque
accru de par exemple huit cas sur 1000
c'est pas beaucoup mais sur 300 millions
d'américains ou sur le canada au complet
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de vies
sauvées ou de mal être sauvées faut
regarder ça d'un point de vue
populationnelle mais c'est vrai que pour
vous comme individu le risque est petit
le risque absolu de manger plus de
charcuterie ben ça dépend combien
mais pourquoi ces salles à manger une
fois par semaine ce programme mais
quelqu'un qui dirait souhaite l étude
des mangeurs manger du bacon tous les
matins avec la mode c'est tout et bien
c'est clair que c'est très mauvais
autant pour le coeur le cancer le
cerveau etc ça discrédite la science du
genre de clientèle à vous servir de
journée
c'est sûr que j'en entends parler comme
le dit lui-même mes collègues ma parle
dans les corridors et il a bien deux
rouges
bon alors il faut toujours revenir sur
lie les grappes
moi ce que je dis toujours c'est pas
vrai que la science en vo comme ça quand
on regarde depuis 30 ans et constant une
alimentation qui plus axé sur les fruits
et légumes les noix les légumineuses ce
adema pour études après le loyer le
meilleur sur des images souveraine de
dart est réducteur les études qui ont
été faites de régression la maladie
coronarienne date des années 90 par dean
ornish et bien documenté ça que quand on
mange plutôt une alimentation de type
végétale à base de végétaux dont on
nope de bonne qualité on a même non
seulement de stabiliser stabilisation
des lésions coronariennes une régression
des blocages fait que c'est pas banal ça
c'est bien démontrer et sa visite est
pas banal c'est démontrer et il se
dément jamais se sont assis non
surprenant 50 experts avec des opinions
un peu différent d'eux
il ya toutes les spectres mais tout le
monde à s'entendre pour les plus de
fruits et légumes que degré entier - de
charcuterie 0 charcuterie de masquer de
cette sécurité
dimitri de toutes sortes de pas dû
beaucoup de sel alors il ya ça c'est
vraiment et je pense qu'un reproche
qu'on fait ces étudiants c'est de
laisser de côté nos visites et en parle
pas de visites en pas d'oubli slip il
parle pas de l'environnement c'est vrai
que c'est le bon dire ben écoutez nous
on parlait de diète l'alimentation mais
en 2019 ne pas parler de l'impact sur la
planète de la diète c'est faible un peu
oui ou non de leurs protéines en fait de
consommer de la viande à l'élevage c'est
ce qu'on a bu beaucoup à l'effet de
serre au gaz à effet de serre alors on
va souhaiter que ben on va voir ce qui
va arriver si un retrait de ces articles
du new york times seulement sont des
journaux sérieux
oui oui oui lol dont il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'auteurs harvard en
particulier toutes les gendarmeries ont
été très agressifs les gens de yei l'oci
aujourd'hui parce que des gendarmes ou
d'adressé dans l'équipe de chercheurs a
mais ceux qui ont été les plus violents
critique c'est walter willet et francky
ou des arbres et bien merci toujours un
plaisir martin juneau
s'ils veulent pas mangé de steaks ce
soit en fout merci